بعد ان كان العام 2019 يتمتع بهدوء النسبي
بالنسبه للصحفيين اصبح العام 2022 النقطه
التي بدات فيها اعداد الضحايا من الصحفيين
بنزياد فالحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا كانت
كفيله بان تكون نقطه التحول ولم تكن
الوحيده بل فقمه الاحتجاجات في ايران اعدد
الانتهاكات بحق الصحفيين
التقرير الذي صدر مؤخرا عن منظمه مراسلون
بلا حدود المعنيه بحريه الصحافه والضحى
اعداد الضحايا من الصحفيين الذين لقوا
حتفهم في سياق ممارسه العمل خلال العقدين
عمو 2002 و20 شهيد ارتفاعا باستهدا في
صحفيين حيث سجل استهداف 58 صحفيا خاصه
ويبقى عام 2012 2013 الاكثر دمويه حيث سجل
مقتل 144 و 142 صحفيا على التوالي العام
2019 كان الاكثره هدوئا للصحفيين والاقل
في عمليات الاستهداف والحصيله الاجماليه
لاخر 20 سنه تتحدث عن مقتل نحو 1700 صحفي
بالرغم من ان كل من سوريا والعراق تصدرتا
ترتيب اخطر الدول على الصحفيين الا ان
تقارير المنظمه والجنه حمايه الصحفيين
اكدت ان السجن الاكبر لحريه الصحافه وقمع
اصحاب المهنه هو ايران
حملات اعتقال وقمع للصحفيين لطالما ارتبطت
بالنظام الايراني الا انها تكثفت بالتزامن
مع الاحتجاجات الحاليه في البلاد
47 صحفيا في سجون النظام العديد منهم من
النساء ما يجعل ايران ثالث اكثر الدول
قمعا للصحفيين على مستوى العالم
اخطار القتل والاعتقال وتكميم الافواه لا
تنحصر في مناطق النزاع بل تتجاوزها الى
المناطق الامنه لتتعدد اشكال التهديد
كالاغتيال ومحاوله عرقله الاقلام التي
تمارس دورها الاساسي في التحقيقات
والقضايا الحساسه اذا عمر العربيه